[Music]
controversial YouTuber named Stephen
Crowder it's very offensive very
expensive we have a higher standard for
monetization YouTube dragged its feet
before taking any action against
conservative commentators Stephen
Crowder we did announce the monetization
change that Stephen Crowder was and it
is crying I don't like it it's a total
move conservative demographic is
it's quite literally dying off there are
a lot of people out there like me like
Joe like our audience who often feel
like they don't have a home they're
Misfits they're not tuning in to Fox
News they're not tuning into a lot of AM
radio it used to be content generators
right who were adding the value to
YouTube go ahead and listen to most of
the podcasts out there right now it is
far more PG vanilla Disney friendly than
what you would hear on basic AM radio
and there's no FCC YouTube demonetizing
uh conservative comedian Stephen Crowder
they said he didn't violate their
policies but they were going to
demonetize the name YouTube Facebook at
one point Twitter these guys should be
in the hot seat it shouldn't be
refreshing it shouldn't be the exception
to the rule it should be the rule I
think Stephen Crowder might have just
revolutionized the way you negotiate
contracts from this moment on and be a
Dead series if you want to be with big
Tech that's fine my issue is don't claim
that you're fighting big Tech and then
do their best Stephen Crowder said sleep
well tomorrow is war it's War they're
literally using this word Civil War war
but I mean that we are an ideological
war uh we really are we are at a
potential Tipping Point in this country
who are you reaching if it's not the
truth and Rumble is willing to gamble
and let the cards fall where they may
and allowing the truth to stand on its
own people are looking for folks to
fight for them
[Music]
oh
that's what you need
what team not alone you can watch other
shows
[Music]
foreign
I'll do it my show will be mug club now
how about that
I can't do the walking thing I don't
have a tux I got a onesie that looks
like a tux
[Music]